welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Star Wars the Clone Wars is
now back in our lives with a seventh
season on Disney plus the centerpiece of
this season will be the concurrent
history of Oda 66 from Revenge of the
Sith the siege of Mandalore and of
course whoa even for regular Watchers of
the Star Wars animated series
molls story is definitely one of the
most confusing like he keeps showing up
at different points in history and the
dude's gotten more replacement legs than
Lieutenant Dan I'm gonna explain malls
updated timeline everything you need to
know about the Star Wars character -
angry to die and thanks to privacy icon
for sponsoring this episode if you sign
up now at privacy calm slash new rock
stars you can get $5 today to use on any
purchase online ok we first met mall in
the panted menace at last we will reveal
ourselves to the Jedi revenge was maul
referring to their well that backstory
was actually revealed in the Maul comics
small was born on Dathomir as a black
male son to mother Talzin tells him led
a group of female dark side which is
called the next sisters and Maul was
born alongside two blood brothers
Farrell and Savage Opress Towson gave
Maul his face tattoos before his first
birthday
Sidious took on Maul as an apprentice
where Maul trained in an acrobatic form
of lightsaber combat called terrace
Cassie which is name dropped as a clue
setting up models reveal in solo teras
kasi Jayden told me
Sidious took mauled the planet of Malick
or a battleground from an ancient Jedi
Sith war Sidious for small to breathe in
the ashes of past Sith warriors from
that battle and Maul experienced a
vision of each of these six deaths that
dramatic trip left him with a rage and a
strong desire for revenge against the
Jedi Order and met soroban Jamal was
talked about so then later when the time
was right Sidious inserted himself into
the Trade Federation drama sparking a
war between the separatists and the
Republic that he could exploit under his
alter-ego cinder sheev Palpatine of
Naboo so that he could one day rename
himself the Senate
genic mall finally revealed leiseth to
the Jedi on Tatooine in an attack on
qui-gon jinn nearly flatly nanny and
then later in that film he gets a
rematch he gets qui-gon and obi-wan on
Naboo
he kills qui-gon but he gets seven and a
half by obi-wan and falls down the
reactor shaft as maul fell he used his
rage and his will to survive to grasp an
air vent he slid down into a trash
container and was taken to a junkyard
world where he lived in a bowels of the
planet and built these spider legs so
that you know we could scream at more
trash heap Cho Maul was found by his
brother Savage gavage took maul back to
Dathomir where Talzin used a Nightsister
magic to restore his sanity and give him
new bipedal robotic legs from here the
brothers joined forces to seek vengeance
against all their enemies at the time
and I list hello there obi-wan Kenobi
they clash with obi-wan twice the Death
Watch join Maul and Savage and a plot to
take back Mandalore from the current
neutral leaders and restore Mandalore to
its ancestral warrior values this grew
into an alliance of crime gangs called
the shadow collective and they
successfully sacked the Mandalorian
throne but Maul challenged Pre Vizsla to
a trial by combat and defeated him using
the dark saber to execute him Death
Watch member poco tanta affected from
all at this point and then Maul used the
previous Mandalorian leader Duchess
Satine an old flame of obi-wan to lure
in Kenobi and then he killed Satine in
front of him but then as Sidious arrived
in lots of Oz and Maul Sivaji died and
Maul gets tortured and taken away by
Sidious for some of the plans we never
got to see Clone Wars continue on with
that story because I got cancelled but
the storyline was continued in the son
of Dathomir comics here we find out that
Maul was imprisoned and tortured by
Sidious in Dooku the mall was able to
escape with the help of his Death Watch
loyalists but that's exactly what city
sudoku wanted because mawla led them to
his mother Talzin
there's a big battle and it ends with
Talzin holding off Sidious so Maul could
escape Grievous killed her
and while retreated back to Mandalore
with a dark saber back in charge of the
planet really a kind of nothing changed
other than moles just angry are and this
is where later this season of Clone Wars
will pick up look folks keeping up with
this content is tough because now we
have to get it all from subscription
services and about you but rather than
stay subscribe to like ten things all
the time I like to only pay for the
content I'm actually
assuming the trick is managing the
credit-card numbers that you give them
to turn on and off when you need them to
well thanks to privacy comm for
sponsoring this video
privacy let's see make online purchases
using virtual burner cards for each kind
of purchase instead of your real card
for everything this protects your
identity and bank information on the
internet and lets you control the limits
on each virtual card so for example I've
set up an account with privacy I've
linked my bank account and created a
card specifically for my monthly Netflix
subscription payment privacy will ding
you with lightning-fast precision if
someone tries to charge a card twice or
if the charge exceeds the amount you set
up for it nice try Netflix I thin its
cheer last month and you will get access
to my card again when stranger things
comes back see no vendor can overcharge
beyond the limit you've set it's simple
it's fast it's really just one click
they also offer these different plans
there's a free one that lets you create
up to 12 cards a month a pro plan where
you can get 36 cards a month and 1% cash
back on purchases and then a team's plan
for small businesses there's also a
privacy Chrome extension where you can
fill out all of your card info to save
time just one click and all your details
are instantly entered head to privacy
comm slash new rockstars and sign up for
an account and as a special treat for my
viewers new customers will automatically
get 5 bucks to spend on your first
purchase for a limited time only
yep that's free money just go to privacy
icon slash new rockstars and sign up now
okay back to mall this season of Clone
Wars
we know from ahsoka tano 'he's book that
Maul and ahsoka dueled during the siege
of Mandalore this season will show said
duel the siege of Mandalore will be led
by ahsoka combined forces with Bo Catan
and clone commander Rex spud during the
siege Sidious as old as 66 will go out
all the clone troopers have these chips
implanted in their brains that causes
them to turn on their Jedi friends but
only Rex will disable that chip and help
ahsoka escape quota cuts the mall we
don't know exactly how he responds to
order 66 it's possible that those ships
were programmed to target and Maul too
you know so like see this could clean
house against anyone who would know
about his conspiracy but really we find
ourselves in an unknown gap of maules
history now we know later on he ends up
retrieving Safa mirror and heads up the
new criminal enterprise called the
crimson dawn that's one with dried moss
no relation and kira from the solo film
i'll come back to this but after all
these events and Star Wars rebels we
actually learned about the final years
of maules life he returns to malloc or
in search of a Sith holocron that he can
use to bring an
into the syph mall and Asoka have a
rematch small blinds kanan jarrus in the
escapes malkor he later shows back up to
combine Sith holocron with a Jedi
holocron he does so he gains his cosmic
wisdom and he hears the words he later
interprets those words to realize that
obi-wan Kenobi is still alive living in
exile on Tatooine samal tracks down an
elderly Ben Kenobi realizes that Kenobi
is there to protect a child of course
Luke they fight but Kenobi defeats them
very quickly in three strokes and
feelings and feels here lying in
Kenobi's arms mile asks Kenobi if the
boy was indeed the chosen one who can
end thus if Kenobi tells him yes and
Maul dies finally at peace you know
until the rise of Skywalker revealed
that the SIP actually survived
everything Luke did but she don't tell
him all that the mystery remains this
gap period between mauls time on
Mandalore to his time running the
Crimson dawn and solo what is the
crimson dawn exactly like it's a gang
but what kind is it just remnants of his
network of the shadow collective
loyalists whatever it is it must be
short-lived
right there's no mention of it one small
shows up in rebels you know a few years
before a new hope stranded on mal Court
well perhaps this Clone Wars season will
set up these still upcoming Kenobi
series yes last we heard Kenobi was
going through some script revisions some
reports it was canceled some other
reports denying it but the little we
know about it is that Kenobi will be set
eight years after order 66 and eleven
years before a new hope meaning it will
be set one year before we saw Maul in
solo so just imagine how dark and
turbulent DUP this crimson dawn Maul
cult must have been to rise as quickly
and then collapse into obscurity I like
to compare mauls history to Breaking Bad
the Clone Wars is kind of like season
one through four of Breaking Bad the
rise of a crime Empire led by a broken
and betrayed man and then Maul and
rebels was kind of like the second half
of the final season of Breaking Bad an
isolated psychopath obsessively
scrambling in his final days therefore I
believe that this dark age of maul the
crimson dawn years will be my favorite
stretch of Breaking Bad the first half
of the final season where we get to see
the corrupt protagonist at the peak of
his power but committing his darkest
sins to try to maintain that power
so what dirtbikes kids will maul
dissolve in a bucket what prisoners will
maul have killed by Nancy's will we get
to see mall grout Akira I am the one who
knocks
whoa comment down below with your mall
theories and keep an eye out for my
breakdown in the details you miss
in the Clone Wars season premiere it's
gonna come later this weekend follow me
on instagram twitter at EA boss hallo
new rock stars and subscribe to new rock
stars here on YouTube for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]